welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn wilshire host and our guest is
Beverly gage a professor of 20th century
US history at Yale University her
teaching and research focused on the
evolution of American political
ideologies and institutions she teaches
courses on terrorism communism and
anti-communism American conservatism and
20th century American politics her first
book the day Wall Street exploded a
story of America in its first age of
Terror examined the history of terrorism
in the late nineteenth and early
twentieth centuries focusing on the 1920
Wall Street bombing today we talk with
her about her forthcoming book gman j
edgar Hoover and the American Century
welcome professor gage thanks for having
me let's begin with an overview of your
book tell us about it sure well g-man
which stands for government man ok is a
new big political biography of someone
that I would describe as really one of
the towering figures for better or worse
of 20th century American politics so
it's about former FBI director J Edgar
Hoover who as many people have pointed
out over the years was one of the
longest serving public servants in the
United States so he became director of
the FBI in 1924 at the ripe old age of
29 and he remained in that job until
nineteen seventy-two so almost half a
century so it's an attempt to really
grapple with Hoover not only as the
villain that he's really become I think
in the popular imagination but is a
really very serious political figure
someone who had a pretty dramatic
influence on American popular political
culture and on the shape of American
government and who was someone who is in
power for at least half of the 20th
century
very long time what led you to write the
book well Hoover actually showed up in
my first book book called the day Wall
Street exploded that you just mentioned
which was about a little known terrorist
attack on Wall Street in 1920 it was the
biggest terrorist attack of its age and
it killed about 38 people on a kind of
ordinary work day at the corner of wall
and broad streets in New York we've
largely forgotten it but at the time it
was this huge deal and this huge
investigation in the very early years of
the FBI and so Hoover is not director at
that point but he's a very young man
kind of working behind the scenes
beginning to think about the issue on
the one hand of terrorism but more
importantly at that moment of political
radicalism and particularly left-wing
radicalism in the United States and so I
encountered him in doing the work on
that project really as a very young man
and what was striking to me was that
there he is he's in his mid 20s at that
point and he has not yet become the
figure that we are all going to get to
know but he's already thinking through
so many of these issues that he's going
to become identified with later on
namely in that case the kind of war
against communism which so much shapes
American politics 90th century how does
your book differ from the many other
books out there about Hoover right well
there are a couple of things that I
think make this book different so Hoover
is someone who's been written about
obviously a great deal i think he is
still a household name for the most part
although when i talk with my students
they know they've heard of him they're
not always a hundred percent sure which
Hoover he is right vacuumer since right
is he recent meeting a little bit are we
still enough enough of a name so anyway
he's been written about obviously for a
long time by lots of people but a lot of
the tradition of writing about Hoover
has been very much a tradition of expose
so most of the big biographies of Hoover
have been books that are seeking to kind
of expose his secrets tell us things
that people didn't know at the time that
he was actually in political power so
that's part of what my book is as well
but it's also trying to
we step back from that a little bit and
assess Hoover not only as someone who's
keeping secrets but someone who plays
this very big role in American politics
and to kind of take him from from the
fringes and this idea of him as a rogue
villain and really put him back at the
center of our political story so I'd say
that's that's piece one not trying to
rewrite that picture of him a little bit
the second thing that the book is doing
is trying to put him in conversation
with really interesting work that's
being done on the kind of history and
evolution of American conservatism in
the 20th century and a lot of that work
tends to kind of look at a resurgence of
grassroots conservatism that begins to
happen in the 60s and 70s and then
ultimately comes of age with Ronald
Reagan and the Reagan presidency in the
80s and this is an effort to recast that
a little bit and to think about someone
like Hoover as an ideological
conservative but an ideological
conservative who holds a whole lot of
state and government power through the
period that we usually think about as
the great age of American liberalism so
again it's sort of recasting him in a
different relationship with American
politics than I think that we've seen
before okay and in doing your research
and I would imagine part of the one of
the big issues is there so much written
about him but you were able to uncover
some things that no other historian has
seen before and also you gain to access
to some files that had never or
collections private collections that had
never been opened before how did you how
did that come to pass and what were some
of your findings I just talked about
Europe you know how you did the research
in general well I'd say the blessing and
the curse of doing research on an
institution like the FBI is that there's
always more to find so that makes it
terrific because there's always material
out there that people haven't really
looked at and haven't scrutinized in a
serious way well in my case is that
though how is that that no one has come
to seen it of
are the files just being made open to
the public is that is that the situation
or there's just so much that it's
impossible for one person to go through
it all right well it's kind of a
combination so this the material that's
at the FBI is constantly being processed
and sent to the National Archives but
we're talking about millions millions of
pages of material something that no
single person could possibly go through
so to some degree you can go to the
National Archives and begin to look
through this material that's been
recently released a lot of the FBI's
material and even pretty far back
historical material even back as early
as the teens of the 20s some of that is
still at the FBI and almost everything
from the 50s 60s and 70s is still at the
FBI and can be acquired through the
Freedom of Information Act and through
filing Freedom of Information Act
requests so what this means is that you
know in my case I happen to be
particularly interested in the FBI's
relationship with conservative
organizations and so I began to file
Freedom of Information Act requests on a
whole variety of conservative
organizations that you know for the most
part people just haven't filed for your
requests about before and so therefore
the material hasn't come to light so
doing research there is a little bit
different because you can't just go and
sit down and have all of it there you
have to actually be rather proactive
about finding it the other question of
course is a redaction which is to say
crossing out the names of people and
also declassification which happens over
time so by the very nature of the
passage of time under our current laws
it means that there's always new
material coming up new material being
released I think the last and really
interesting thing that's happening is
that the generation of people who knew
Hoover in the 60s and 70s or who were
officials with him etc many of those
people have become quite elderly or have
died over the last 40 years and so their
private collections have also begun to
come to light and have been gathered
together in a serious way for instance L
Patrick gray who was Hoover successor at
the FBI very briefly
sort of between the time that Hoover
died in 1972 and the time that the kind
of Watergate scandal really began to
emerge in 73 and 74 he's there in this
very critical moment and his son has
actually gathered together a lot of his
papers and pulled together a pretty
serious collection that hasn't been very
widely used so what if some of the
things that you were able to find that
you know no one has seen before for
instance or anything in particular that
was surprising that you came across
right well in terms of some of the
documents about you know Hoover's
relationship with with important
conservative figures the conservative
movement I think you can see a real set
of kind of serious ideological back and
forth that's going on there I think we
tend to have an image of Hoover as being
kind of a rogue figure who's getting
what he wants by blackmailing people
writing I mean certainly this is to some
degree at least in part of what he did
but one of the things that I think
that's interesting at looking at these
these documents that haven't been
studied a lot is to see what a careful
architect he was about building a pretty
widespread political grassroots base for
the FBI through these organizations so
everything from women's clubs to the
American Legion to more kind of overt
overtly conservative grassroots
organizations you can actually see his
skills I think as a politician in that
sense in ways that aren't as often
recognized and then there are all sorts
of you know just sort of interesting
little anecdotes that come up in the
papers as well ways that he deals with
the press I mean particularly Hoover as
a young man you can see him sort of
struggling in 1935 to invite certain
reporters into the FBI and then they
betray him and he denounces them and you
can just so I think you actually get a
very lively sense of who he is as a
person again beyond this sort of rather
one-dimensional views we how would you
characterize him as a person from from
your research that you've done so far
right well I think he is a rigid person
is a person who likes to be in control
and I think that those things are not
probably terribly surprising to people
but you know one of the things that is
interesting is really thinking about him
in fact as a person as someone who as a
young man liked to go out to nightclubs
and stay out late as someone who is
cracking jokes with his friends within
the FBI someone who's actually having a
real struggle about what it means to be
in this position of power is clean very
tightly to it in certain ways so I would
say I wouldn't necessarily say that i
like j edgar hoover a whole lot in the
sense that I would you know wat to sit
down and in mesh my life with his
although I suppose my life is kind of
invest with a certain way but I do feel
more sort of empathetic to him and I
have seen him come alive as a person in
a way again that these these pictures of
him as a as a pure kind of almost
inhuman villain I think don't quite
capture one of the things you do talk
about in the book whoops I guess when we
call the more salacious kind of rumor or
gossip is his relationship with Clyde
Tolson and the conjecture as to whether
he is homosexual or not what have you
found along those lines anything well I
think we're probably never going to have
an absolute smoking gun in the sense
that we know you know the most intimate
details of what Hoover did in his own
bedroom but in fact we don't know that
about most people so in some ways that's
not particularly unique what's really
interesting to me particularly about
Hoover and Tolson is it's very clear
that they were each other's chief
emotional supports that they maintained
a forty year relationship with each
other a kind of deeply loyal and
intimate relationship which I think it's
not a stretch to imagine being sexual
though we have no particularly distinct
evidence about that but what's been
really striking to me and I think the
ways
which the book will be sort of useful
and talk about this in different ways is
just how public that relationship was
and I think people have an idea that to
have a partnership like that a
partnership where many people openly
kind of speculated that these men were
having a homosexual relationship that to
have had that in the mid century United
States you would have needed to be
somehow deeply deeply hidden and on the
one hand you can see this as a as a
hidden and closeted relationship but on
the other hand they were a very public
couple I mean you invited Edgar to
dinner and you were also going to invite
Clyde and so they were accepted and
functioned really as a social couple
over the long term and I think it kind
of up ends some of our contemporary
binaries about you know they're straight
and there's gay and there's no sort of
other way to function socially I think
they were sort of a unique we're
interesting case study in it but during
that time period when they were so
together and went out socially and
everyone invited them together as a
couple almost like it was a marriage it
strikes me as somewhat hypocritical for
him to then have behaved toward the gay
world in the manner that he did will you
be talking about that at all in your
book absolutely and this is one of the
great i mean hoover is if he is anything
right he's someone who is full of
contradictions right we can call them
contributions we can call them hip
pockets and you which often is not
inaccurate either but yeah I mean Hoover
is certainly one of the architects of
what is now described as the lavender
scare right which sort of parallels the
Red Scare particularly in the 40s and
50s in which homosexuality is understood
to be a national security threat and so
it's a very perplexing situation here is
a man that many people understand to at
least be suggestively homosexual right
who is militantly also cracking down on
homosexuals and so I think we have to
understand this both as as a kind of
defense of his own position and I think
more interestingly
see the ways in which he crafts the FBI
as a kind of defense against these
accusations in part right a very very
masculine kind of male centered
institution right and and with a sort of
very interesting and distinct public
image this image of the g-man that
emerges in this moment I think one of
the things that's going to be really fun
to play with in the in the final version
of the book are these these
representations of a certain kind of
masculinity how people understood that
then and how we want to understand it
now how do you think that Hoover in that
span of 50 years shaped the American
political culture well I think Hoover
did a couple of things so one thing is
that he though we tend to as I said
again think of him as this kind of rogue
figure you know in many ways he is
adopting what are the essential kind of
liberal techniques of State Building
government efficiency kind of insulating
administrative managers and bureaucrats
from the evil influences of politics all
of these things which often progressives
embraced which certainly the New Deal
embraced in many ways the strengthening
of the federal government all of these
things that we tend to think of as being
somehow inherently liberal or
progressive or often framed in that way
and the way we talk about American
politics he sort of takes these tools of
State Building and uses them to build a
very different part of of the American
state and of the American government so
I think he's very interesting as a kind
of bureaucratic architect and as it as a
kind of case study in that in terms of
his political influence I do think that
he was one of the most important people
certainly within the government itself
in sort of containing and limiting the
left in the 20th century and I think in
some ways this is one of the biggest
messages of the book is as I said I talk
about him as
a conservative who held a whole lot of
government power in an age when we tend
to think of as the age of liberalism
right this kind of mid-century moment
and one of the things that he spent a
lot of his life doing is watching and
policing kind of radical movements on
the left and I think in the end kind of
containing and shaping American culture
both through kind of policing left and
through very overtly promoting a
conservative anti-communist message that
had great influence and resonance in the
United States okay and your book will be
out in uh 2014-15 so I got a few more
years of working well we will certainly
watch for that because I think it will
be a very interesting read thank you so
much for being here today with us and
sharing some of your work great thanks
Marilyn for more information about
professor gauge and her research please
visit our website at yale edu slash
mcmillan report be sure to join us again
for another episode of the macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale
you